this is the moment the first bomb
exploded in kampala
at a checkpoint at the central police
station
exactly three minutes later
a second went off near the parliament
building three suicide bombers were
involved they were killed along with
three other people dozens were injured
this footage was released by the police
who said a fourth man was arrested and a
suicide jacket found at his home very
unfortunate it's happening at such a
time that we're trying to go back to our
normal livelihoods
so if these people can
come at such a
premises of police
and
and set off a bomb
then you know things are not good
the aftermath shows how powerful the
blasts were broken windows burning
vehicles and terrified people
police say the attacks were carried out
by a gang working alongside the allied
democratic forces the armed group has
its roots in uganda but is now based in
the democratic republic of congo its
fighters have killed thousands of people
in the east in recent years
the hallmarks of the attack clearly
indicates that the edf linked
radicalized groups
who still have a desire
to carry out lethal attacks on soft
targets using suicide attackers
and improvised explosive devices
behind these attacks
this attack follows two others last
month one killed a waitress in a
restaurant and a second on a bus two
days later injured several people
isil claimed those attacks
the adf has pledged its allegiance to
the group the involvement of the ugandan
anime in the peacekeeping nations
in the region especially in somalia
makes uganda a target
of some of these groups
what's happening in uganda also comes at
a time when the military is planning to
deploy its soldiers to eastern drc to
help congolese troops and un
peacekeepers fight adf there they'll
help congolese troops and u.n
peacekeepers to fight aid air
catherine soy al jazeera